[Music]
i'm not going to say it doesn't ever
happen but not very often and we don't
drive a lot of ferraris my name's andy k
i'm a private investigator and i'm also
the owner of k and associates
investigations here in los angeles for
about the last 30 years today i'm going
to be looking at private investigator
scenes from movies and television
what do you want hds sir and how are you
this afternoon alrighty then i've been
a delivery guy a couple of times i've
been a waiter i've actually asked a
mater d to give me the bottle of wine to
deliver the table one time so yeah it
happens there's actually laws against
impersonating another person walking up
with the outfit
nobody's going to say anything about it
if you go up there and say hey i am
fedex then you're stepping over a line
that was a close one ladies and
gentlemen when little animals go missing
unless we have good information that
somebody has stolen it or it's a big dog
expectations are pretty low it happens
and we've gotten some back nobody's
going to do it like that because you
would not know first off that the dog
was going to be anywhere accessible in
the first place that the guy is going to
even answer the door in the second place
there is just so much presumption in
this case that it would just never
happen that way
except for jim carrey
no problem it gets flooded we'll just
wait a few seconds
all that planning just to be caught at
the end with a baseball bat
usually we don't have to worry about
getaway the big thing about being a
private investigator is to be private so
that they don't ever know we were there
i would give this clip a two it's
designed to be comedic and it's very
good at it
sergeant we haven't met yeah i know you
are and i'd prefer if you didn't tamper
with any of the evidence
the police officer first thing he said
was i prefer you not be disturbing our
evidence and that's exactly correct they
would have never let him in those doors
at that point once they were there they
would have taken over the scene the
disdain for what he was saying shows you
that they are not big fans of private
investigators which is a lot of the
times the situation with police officers
a lot of times we are
working with the police a lot of times
we are working against the police
left-handed oh i'm amazed you didn't
notice all you have to do is look around
this flat coffee table on the left-hand
side coffee mug handle pointing to the
left power sockets habitually use the
ones on the left you can notice things
that are out of sync i mean that's
extreme for sure and all that's going to
come out in pathology anyway they're
going to know if he's right or
left-handed there should be
dozens and dozens of photos of the crime
scene so they're going to notice some of
those things there's nothing there that
wouldn't come out through the normal
process anyway and the private
investigator is not going to be a part
of that there's a lot of different
things you can tell about people from
looking at them and appearance wise but
if you start assuming too much you might
have fallen into a trap for what they're
you know trying to make themselves be
portrayed as so you
look you don't draw conclusions that way
i would rate that at
probably a five just because it's
entertaining and you have to make it
make it such otherwise it's not gonna
work
hi this is gia
well there's a whole lot of violations
of law in this one we have this thing
called expectation of privacy that we're
supposed to work within
and so if you can see something from
public view
without magnifying it you can record it
if
you can hear a conversation in public
again the expectation of privacy is gone
so you can do that
taping phone calls it's a two-party
state
it's in california obviously they said
they're in west hollywood so you cannot
record that phone call if she was
licensed she wouldn't be for much longer
if she was caught doing it you can get
the information other ways and
you definitely couldn't use it in any
kind of a court or prosecution because
they're going to toss it all out so it's
it's worthless for anything other than
developing
corroboration with other evidence that
you find
hey
something's happening
i need to get over here right away
i've had situations like this where we
actually just rented the apartment
across the street that way if i can open
my window and see into theirs it's fair
game
so
there's ways around what she's doing
and this is obviously an area where she
wouldn't expect anybody to be looking in
on her although if people have public
access to that roof she could also be in
the same situation say it's a rooftop
bar and she's just sitting there at a
table she has the right if she can see
it i have to get a closer look yes
sometimes cameras do come in handy now
there's
much smaller magnifications that we use
that do the same job
we also use drones a lot with
magnification because if we can see it
from there we can get anywhere on it if
it's in public space
we can magnify on it i'll give this clip
two stars just because it's
absolutely
nothing a private investigator is going
to do
did you converse with harlan at that
time
well he was there we must have spoke in
his study
i don't think so from an interrogation
standpoint it was actually pretty good
he
left information out of the questions so
that they could try to extrapolate on it
and that way you can see which way
they're going you could see that don
johnson was coached a little bit on how
to react while you're trying to hide
something and you're trying to convey
something else so it was it was done
well just the way he he led his
expressions and then oh yeah you know
kind of things things like that the
things that you look for are
when they look away a lot when they have
to stumble when they say things that are
just out of line anyway they try to
divert from something when you ask a
question now
a lot of people will hang their hat off
of watching some ex-fbi agent tell you
how to read people and once you do that
you start missing everything else you
really have to trust yourself and your
interactions with people so you really
have to pay attention to those body cues
and facial cues without becoming a
victim of
counting on every single one to mean a
certain thing who hired you
i do not know
an envelope of cash showed up at my
apartment yesterday with a news clip and
a throbby's death well actually just
today we got a case where
we have an anonymous client i know she's
a female that's all i really know about
her so it's very strange but yeah it
happens you really want to know who your
clients are the majority of the time i
give it
seven
one of the more realistic portrayals so
far
what makes you certain that your husband
is um
involved with someone a wife can tell
good scene now as i recall in this movie
that was not the actual person she was
portraying herself to be but she was
right about that statement when she said
a woman knows these things
she was right women no we actually keep
the numbers every year
because we do a lot of these cases all
over the globe it's always between
96 and 99 of the women that hire us are
right guys are about 50 they
they know about half the time if it's
really happening or not they just tend
to be
more
weary of other men around or things like
that so
it's about 50 percent with guys about 96
to 99 with women one of the big
giveaways is being overprotective of the
cell phones and the pads in any of their
other devices we've got a great digital
forensics department somebody brings us
a computer or a telephone
we can receive you know retrieve
you know deleted text deleted pictures
all those kind of things mrs mulray this
this type of investigation uh can be
hard on your pocketbook uh it takes
time money doesn't matter to me mr
gettys most investigations are expensive
it's not a cheap thing to get into for
infidelity cases i've had cases go where
we were watching somebody 24 7 for
three weeks and i got on the phone with
my client and i said hey he's not doing
what you think he's doing
and she says andy please stay on this i
know
and so we did and honestly it wasn't two
days later before he was
at one of the high-end hotels in beverly
hills with two prostitutes and then
three days later we end up at a town
house up in agora where he paid for it
and he's had a woman living there with
him for
years that nobody knew anything about so
sometimes it takes a long time i would
rate the accuracy of this scene a 10 out
of 10.
[Music]
following people on foot you definitely
want to do a lot of the things he did
stay out of sight don't look ridiculous
enough to everybody else around you that
they're saying hey there's a guy like
hiding behind the wall watching you go
around the corners you don't want to do
that you always have to look just like
you belong there because it's not just
that person you have to worry about
seeing you you have everybody else that
if you're acting
weird and stalkerish they're going to go
tell somebody the last thing you want to
do if you're following somebody is have
the police pull you over to ask you what
you're doing that kind of ends the
surveillance right there quite often
when we end up in a on foot situation
where we're doing a surveillance it
started off in a vehicle
so
you don't know exactly what you're going
to be able to do and like i talked about
in some of the other situations you have
to be able to flow with it as things
change
[Music]
almost all my guys when they're doing
surveillance they'll have a couple extra
shirts or tops or maybe a pair of shorts
anything that they can switch out fast
to make themselves look different and
not catch the eye over and over and over
again because if they're walking in an
area where there's not a lot of people
for a long time a lot of people take
walks and parks things like that so you
have to kind of be ready to be on foot
[Music]
it wasn't terrible you want your
disguise not to be so
ridiculous that it's noticed as
ridiculous because then they're gonna
pay attention to you his was a little
over the top there i'd give him seven
eight
we'll go eight
[Music]
the biggest misconception people have
about private investigators is that
we're always in gun fights and we're out
arresting people and that's not very
often what happens i'm not going to say
it doesn't ever happen but
not very often
and we don't drive a lot of ferraris i
would give this clip a 2.
[Music]
in that scene it's much better than
watching the subject of the
investigation being followed by a red
ferrari
half a car length behind him and not
noticing it if you can't be out of sight
blend in you want to use cars that
fit in everywhere i mean we use a lot of
priuses in los angeles the other thing
is anytime you're following somebody and
you
end up in a situation where in a lot of
traffic there's odds are they're going
to take a lot of turns
things like that of course
use a very inconspicuous car
and also try to use several that way
somebody can leapfrog these we can have
a car on the opposite way and if they
come and we know that this one's going
to take a left hey coming towards you
then you're already in the street over
you pick up the car you go off the next
one turns in behind and then tries to
leapfrog ahead if we have to speed we do
it it was amazing because he was
actually keeping an okay distance but
there was never ever any traffic in
between them
[Music]
woman parks and he stops right in the
lane and sits and watches her that's a
sure way to be seen
so
not a good tale
if you think somebody's tailing you
start making a unnecessary turns into
places that are odd and then make
multiple turns make them follow you into
those turns i'll give them five because
i like jimmy stewart remember there was
no physical evidence connecting door
lang to the deuce place out in the woods
meaning it probably didn't happen out
there yeah it still happens a lot we use
a lot of big white boards with a lot of
drawings through in this and then a lot
of those get erased as we go and we have
lots of mirrored rooms that the same
thing happens with dry erase and we put
pictures on so we can see them and as
things develop and change most cases
don't need that kind of investigation
but we use it a lot
the rest of the family they don't really
talk to auntie there's a whole plethora
of things that we can do that law
enforcement can't do we can talk to
people i don't have to read you your
rights i can start questioning you from
the beginning with the intent of having
you confess to me obviously the biggest
thing is i can go anywhere in the world
and work
and i don't have to let anybody know i'm
there and we don't need to take a ton of
time for approvals so if you tell me
that you need to have a certain thing
done we can prioritize it because you're
paying us to do it whereas law
enforcement may never prioritize it so
they may never get to it just because
they're overrun in that part he did
pretty good i thought
in this scene you've got a father who's
looking for a lost daughter he's
obviously very bereaved i think he's
doing the right thing by going through
this i think this is a very common scene
i think that
a lot of people do these type of things
when this happens even before they call
us
social media websites places where they
have memberships things like that are
always important in those kind of
investigations we employ them a lot
some of the times you will use
photographs and things to do reverse
imaging now i'm not talking about doing
a google reverse image we use a lot of
the same soft and hardware that the fbi
uses that a lot of law enforcement uses
and it's only available to licensed
investigators or law enforcement so
we have very good people that go and dig
this stuff out and a lot of times if you
have a daughter that's missing or a son
that's missing
if we can have their computers we can
get a lot of information about what
their thought process was before they
ended up missing there is no such thing
as secure on the internet nowhere if it
can't be gotten right now it'll be
available some other time you just see
what happened to facebook where mark
zuckerberg's phone numbers and
everything else ended up hacked from his
own site so
nothing is safe i don't care who you are
i don't care what site it is if you're
putting it out there you might as well
expect that it's going to be accessible
to anyone so
at some point if the right person wants
to get in there and dig long and hard
enough and invest whatever it is time or
money they're going to find it i would
give this a 10 out of 10. it's very
accurate depiction of what would happen